frétillement de koudougou dans une école
de pêche
quoi de plus gratifiant point
professionnels de la mer un don du ciel
mais savez vous travaillez pour la vie -
5 jan aps - voilà bobigny - dans la
famille depuis plus d'une semaine
dès 5 heures du matin ces soldats de la
mer
le patron et ses équipiers sont en
action 2 oui le produit représente
plusieurs tonnes de couleurs où il doit
être mis à l'abri de la houle et en
sécurité
les espèces dangereuses sont écartés du
vivier
[Musique]
sympathie d'ajouter fini d'achever la
wake up et senna les mets ta troupe
assuré bâtisse
autre étape de la matinée des élections
la zone de cantonnement toujours à
cherchèrent à quelques mètres de la côte
les poissons placées dans ce vivier sont
récupérées à l'aide de filtres tout un
plaisir pour ces hommes de les voir
nouveau frétillent dans l'embarcation
sur cette plage du bourg de fond l'ail
et la vente s'organise
c'est aussi une aubaine pour ces
marchands de noix trois matches cabinet
hfe gary neville valley problème très
naïve est bon ou pas c est que les
poissons le maximum pour nous de sa vie
répond d'autres lendemains pour nous ça
travail convenablement et cahiers ces
petits poissons est encore ultime
compris
c'est tout mon plaisir mon esprit je
suis à la retraite tous les jours dès
qu'il y en a sur je la fais à l'âge de
ma naissance
depuis petit cochon connaissent alors je
me retrouve dans mon à partir de samedi
et dès 6h du matin
une fois aux couleurs où sera organisé
dans le bourg de fonnier h el cheikh